and then on the other side is we got
planners that giveth they're all like
Dupree McBrayer a sea of them Queens is
that they're also going to put back
George Murphy back spasms and all I said
this at the beginning of the half he's
never missed a practice the senior from
San Antonio he's never missed a game the
lowest number of minutes he's ever
played for the Golden Gophers 12 tonight
he has played like just for one doesn't
the business this is awesome by coach
Pitino sure is to give this young man
who has meant so much to this Minnesota
program another chance just to be on the
floor during this moment George picks up
the foul as Coffey was driving
and now you hear the Minnesota faithful
giving him his due
chanting his name emotions have to be
running high absolutely as the freshman
comes in Murphy's gone stuff and Here
Come a cheers yeah we wanted to give him
a curtain call that's a last ones
Schettino second leading rebounder in
big 10 history second team all-big ten
this year for the third consecutive year
in big 10 history he trails that I
mentioned this earlier only Jerry Lucas
of Ohio State you talk about a flagship
player and who you try to build around
and that's exactly what Richard Pitino
tried to do but this is a these are the
moments we saw him the other night you
see him again tonight with sewing they
were heartbreaking but for him and what
he is meant to go for nation listed the
numbers never missing a practice never
missing a game showing up here's the
emotions now for America here coffee
[Applause]
everything out there on the floor that's
one of the amazing things about this
term and I see such joy on the one end
and then on the other end you have guys
like Murphy their careers are ending for
everybody else the season is ending the
agony of the beat
[Applause]